This was a statistic that just
absolutely shocked and staggered me when
I went through the Intel intelligence
literature,
so you know,
it is illegal in the United States to
induct anybody who has an Iq of less
than 83 and the reason for that is you
know that the American armed forces have
been conducting intelligence research
for like more than 100 years and that
was partly because they needed a way of
sorting people rapidly during times of
military expansion during war time.
But it was also because Iq tests and
especially in the early part of the 20th
century were used to identify,
let's say the deserving poor who could
really benefit from additional
educational attainment and advancement
in the unit.
And the military was hoping to identify
people from lower class strata that can
be streamed into say,
officer training programs and so forth
or,
or even skills training programs to.
To move people from the underclass into
at least the working class and maybe
above.
So they had a bloody stake in this man.
They wanted to find people,
they want it to sort them properly and
they wanted to do social good when they
weren't just trying to win a war,
let's say,
which often also is social good,
but what happened was that by,
I don't remember when this legislation
was introduced,
but it wasn't.
It was in the later part of the 20th
century,
but there are basic finding.
Was that by say the 19 eighties,
they had determined that if you had an
Iq of less than 83,
there was not a damn thing that the unit
that the army could do,
the armed forces could do to transform
you into someone who could do something
that was more productive than
nonproductive,
and the terrible thing about that is
that it's about 10 percent of the
population and so they look at a
statistic like that and you think,
oh my God,
you've got this,
this,
this enterprise,
this massive enterprise that's
chronically hungry for people.
Right?
It's always,
they're always looking for people who
are really oriented towards taking
people from the underclass and lower
working class and pushing them up.
The societal strata and during war time
there actually desperate to bring in
recruits period and their conclusion is
that 10 percent of the population can't
be trained to do anything.
Anything sufficiently useful to make
them militarily operable.
It's just.
I just read that my jaw just dropped.
It's like in the United States we have
about 330 million people and because of
the distribution,
the relatively normal distribution of Iq
scores about 16 percent of 85 or what?
They're not going to graduate school.
No,
it means that from,
from what I've read practically,
it means the wanderlust company has
actually done a really.
They have a nice Iq tests from the
commercial perspective,
you know,
it's actually psychometrically valid and
they've linked Iq levels to a job.
Specifically the job categories,
you know,
I know not a lot.
I was going to say is they're not only
not going to graduate school,
they're not going to find a,
a stable
job that pays a livable wage.
Especially even given that so many of
the service jobs now require fair,
high degree of computational savvy or
leader built.
No,
I'm not computation,
but ability to interact with complex
computational technology,
the typical till ladder at a checkout
market or or the Mcdonald's because the
dongles is actually very complicated,
is often far beyond the ability of
people who are on the low end of the
intelligence distribution and they
claimed,
I think it was wonderlic,
although it might know it might've been.
It might've been hunt.
What's his name?
These ICU researcher.
Is it earl haunt?
I think possibly what he claimed that
that if you have an Iq of below 90,
that it's.
It's difficult.
It's difficult for you to read well
enough to translate what you're reading
into action,
so you can't actually read instructions
and follow them.
You don't have that level of literacy.
That's correct,
yeah.
I was going to say that in in the United
States,
this bottom 16 percent translates into
51 million people,
including $13 million children who are
in school.
Right.
This is a very difficult problem.
Now I knew earl hunter.
He passed away.
I knew him pretty well.
He also would say that there is this a
cognitive segregation in society.
This is a point that Charles Murray
makes an often asked,
you know,
when's the last time you had someone
over for dinner who wasn't a college
graduate?
Well that was something that Marie and
Bernstein wrote about in their book the
bell curve,
which really struck me because I read
that book twice unlike most of the
people criticized it and you know,
we're one of the things that they
pointed out in there,
it was,
look the typically the typical educated
person thinks that someone isn't very
bright if they have an Iq of 150.
So you at graduate level,
Phd Level Research Institutions,
right?
Because 115,
there's as many people at 115 and above
as there are at 85 and below.
And so it's a minority of the population
and that's the top 15 percent.
And you know,
that's,
that's the dollar undergraduate people
have.
See I'm a clinical psychologist and I've
dealt with people who had,
I ranges in the low eighties and tried
to find them jobs and tried to train
them.
And I,
I have some real knowledge about the
stunning gap between people at the low
end of the ICU distribution and the high
end,
and it's,
it's no bloody wonder,
people hate Iq research and intelligence
research because it reveals a set of
seriously,
a dismal facts about the incredible
range of ability among human beings.
Well,
yes,
this is true.
And moreover I would add to this that
people in universities,
professors and a couple of graduate
students,
uh,
have a hard time understanding what the,
what everyday life is like.
If you have an Iq of 84,
85 and we're making your way,
you're living independently.
You were making your way in the world
five.
It is a challenge.
I mean,
just,
just barely begins to describe it.
I had a,
I had a client who,
he probably had an Iq of under 80
nonverbal portion of it anyways.
And um,
he was indistinguishable in physical
appearance from,
from let's say,
I hate to use the frame normal person,
but there's nothing more that marked him
out about particularly intellectually
impaired,
you know.
And uh,
I tried at one point,
this is this,
this was so,
so telling to me I got him a volunteer
job,
which by the way is very difficult.
It's harder to get a volunteer job in a
real job because you have to do police
screening and all sorts of things and
the selection process is just as
extreme.
But I eventually ended up getting him a
job at a bike store,
bike slash bookstore and at that place
couldn't hold him once the subsidy
program had expired.
And then I got him a job at a charity
and his job was to fold letters into
three so that they can be put into
envelopes.
Well,
that sounds easy except that he also had
a bit of a motor tremor and you know,
it took me about 30 hours to train him
to fold up a piece of paper with
sufficient precision so that it can be
put in an envelope rapidly so that the
envelope wasn't so mangled that it would
get stuck in the automatic sorting
machine.
How,
in other words,
high performance demands on him too.
He had to whip through those letters
pretty quickly and then sometimes the
letters would have a photograph appended
to them that was stapled on and they
weren't always stapled on in the same
place,
so then he had to calculate how to fold
the paper over the photograph without
bending the photograph in precise third
so that would still fit in the envelope,
and then he had to separate the French
letters from the English letters and
associate them with the proper envelopes
and that level of complexity just did
him in.
Let
me say two things.
One is I hope common sense and the other
is pretty provocative.
The common sense thing is we have to be
very careful when we have these
discussions not to devalue the human
dignity of people who are in the upper
end of the distribution and if there's
one criticism that is fair is sometimes
in these conversations it sounds like
we're devaluing people at the lower end
of the distribution and we have to be
very careful that we don't do that.
A human has dignity
and Iq is not the most important thing
that defines human beings even
associated with wisdom.
It's not necessarily associated with
truth or with courage or with many
virtues that how did it all with being
likable or on the psychometric
psychometric relationship between
intelligence and conscientiousness is
zero.
Right?
We have to make that point.
Yes,
I.
I agree.
I'm trying to make the point about how
difficult it is for people who are on
the low end of the cognitive spectrum to
survive in a,
in an increasingly complex,
cognitively sophisticated environment,
jobs are just disappearing.